في تداعيات الهجوم على مطار السليمانيه
شماليه العراق والذي نسب الى تركيا وبينما
تضاربت الانباء حول محاوله اغتيال فاشله
طالت قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قصد
مظلوم عبدي في المطار خرج عبدي نفسه لاحقا
لمهاجمه الرئيس التركي اتهمه بخلط الاوراق
والبحث عن ذرائع تخدم مصالحه في مرحله
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
بحسب تصريحاته عبد اكد وجود غرف عمليات
مشتركه باشراف التحالف الدولي مع قوات
محاربه الارهاب في العراق و كردستان
العراق لمحاربه داعش وهو ما لا يقبل به
اردوغان على حد تعبيره سبق لرئيس حزب
الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني بافل طالباني
ان قام بزياره عبدي في مقر اقامته في شمال
شرقي سوريا في اواخر العام الماضي وهو ما
اثار غضب تركيا التي تعارض تعاون الحزب
المستمر منذ سنوات مع قصد تشير التقارير
الى ان انقره اراده اي صاله رساله الى
قاده حزب الاتحاد الوطني في معقله بمدينه
السليمانيه بسبب علاقاته مع قوات قصد
المدعومه ايضا من واشنطن فعبدي لم يكن
بمفرده عند استهداف المطار بل كان برفقه
مسؤولينا امريكيين من التحالف الدولي الذي
تقوده واشنطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات